david testo est sorti du placard il y a
huit ans le réalisateur paul émile
d'entremont l'a convaincu de raconter
son parcours pour faire avancer la cause
pour découvrir la réalité des athlètes
homosexuels
je voulais voir un peu plus tant
qu'espace est-ce qu'il est toujours
admissibles ou toujours permis d'être
homophobe et malheureusement dans le
monde des sports c'est toujours le cas
aujourd'hui david testo et professeur de
yoga heureux totalement déconnecté du
soccer un sport qui l'a délaissée
après c'est à vous et à moi j'étais au
courant
directeur sportif de l'impact en 2007
nick de santis n'a pas fait cas de
l'homosexualité de david testo qui
l'avait lui même amené à montréal
personne sentais que ça alors c'était
notre canal vestiaire il s'est senti
tellement confiant que c'était le bon
moment
moi je le dis si tu te sens confortable
vas-y la ligne c'est aussi l'histoire de
l'ex patineuse de vitesse de calibre
olympique anastasia bio 6 et de broc
mégalis un ex-gardien de but acquis
junior hockeyeuses il ya beaucoup de
jeunes athlètes gais et lesbiennes trans
bi sexuel qui abandonne le sport
complètement même s'ils ont du talent
même six ans la motivation c'est juste
trop difficile
non c'est connu que dans la lnh par
exemple il ya des joueurs qui sont gays
mais qui ne sortiront pas du placard du
moins pas maintenant ce documentaire
s'infiltre dans la vie des proches de
ces athlètes d'une maman qui refuse
d'abord de reconnaître l'homosexualité
de son fils et sa note à une amie qui
chante la pomme à son bon copain
2010neuf révéler son homosexualité en
milieu sportif demeure un pensez-y bien
une situation compliquée où je sors
d'une manière et ça va compliquer plus
les choses il faut te sentir bien dedans
quand tu sors avec ça si vous voulez car
il faut quand même avoir des appuis
jean françois poirier radio-canada
mourir